okay so what we're going to do today is we're
going to explain very precisely what is meant
by the 700 billion pounds that has been given out
by the government since the beginning of Covid
so people who've been watching this channel
from the start or even in the last few months
will be aware that I keep going on and
on about this number 700 billion pounds
that's been given out by the government
it's an enormous amount of money
It's £14,000 for every single man or woman
in the country so if you don't have your
£14,000 someone else has got it, in my opinion
it's at the heart of this financial crisis
um I predicted that because of it at the very
beginning of Covid I said we would get a
cost of living crisis; of inflation, of increasing
asset prices, increasing inequality...
so if you understand this £700 billion then you
can understand a lot of what's happening...
it's also an opportunity to attack thegovernment,
ask them where it is, ask them who has it
because it is now held by the richest peoplein
society but if you're going to do that you need
to understand precisely what it's meant, we've had
a few questions about people saying you know what
exactly is that number, where do you get it from?
& we're going to explain that all very clearly today
so first of all what is the 700 billion pounds? the
700 billion pounds is the total government deficit
since the beginning of Covid if anyone doesn't
understand these terms don't worry because it's
going to be explained very clearly it's the total
government deficit since the beginning of covid
which is also the same as the total increase
in government debt since the beginning of covid
which you can understand that's the total amount
of money given out since the beginning of covid
um it's it's a public record number we'll put a
little link to just a public website that shows
exactly the government debt so you can see exactly
how much has increased um and what it is is the
total amount of government spending over and
above government taxation so when the government
spends money but funds it through taxation that
doesn't increase the amount of money in society
it just moves it around so if I come to you and
I tax you 100 pounds and I use that money to
pay school teachers to pay doctors to pay nurses
it doesn't increase or decrease money in society
it simply moves it from one person to another
no increase in total amount of money in society
but when the government spends money without
taxing that does increase money in society
um and I think it's important
to understand how that works so
the first thing to understand is okay if
if they're spending money and they're not
getting it from taxation, where are they getting it
from? now that 700 billion pounds has been funded
in in basically two ways so 450 billion of the 700
billion has been funded by QE quantitative easing
um that is a term that confuses a lot of people
and we will explain it and the other 250 billion
pounds has been borrowed essentially from the
private sector from individuals and we will
get into that as well this is more 450 fromQE
(quantitative easing) and 250 from traditional
borrowing now let's start with the £450bn Q.E.
becausethat confuses a lot of people and it also
shows you really neatly how this leads to
cash accumulation by individuals in society
so QE which stands for Quantitative Easing is a
concept which has confused a lot of people and
I'm going to provide a slightly simplified way of
understanding it which I think helps understand
crucially how it affects the economy in society
so I'm gonna step forward that when you hear QE
what you should understand is that that is the
Central Bank in this case the Bank of England
printing money and lending it to the government
so you should understand that the centralbank
Bank of England here or Federal Reserve in the US
European Central Bank (ECB) in Europe
prints money and lends it to the government
and this is one way that the government can
finance its spending, now I'm going to briefly
elaborate a little bit on this simplification
because I know there'll be people who will be
watching will say that's not what QE is, that's
not how QE works but if you don't understand
this slightly more detailed explanation of QE
what you should keep in your head is that QE is
when the Central Bank prints money and lends it to
the government okay in actuality what happens is
the government borrows money from the
private sector from individuals from banks
and at the same time the Central Bank buys
those loans from the banks now imagine
you are the private sector you are the banks
and the government borrows money from you the
government borrows £100 it gives you an IOU
for £100... IOU £100... £110 plusinterest
in a year's time then the Bank ofEngland
comes in and buys the IOU from you
for £100 or maybe for £101
so you lent money to the government
and then you immediately sold that debt
for the same price at the central bank
effectively it's as if you weren't there right
you made the loan to the government then you got
rid of the loan you're a middleman and the
end result is that the government owes money
to the central bank and the central bank has given
money to the government you see what I'm saying?
technically the central bank doesn't lend the
money directly to the government there's a middle
man between who basically stands in the middle
and takes the money from Central Bank and gives
it to the government but that is not particularly
relevant for the end result, the end result is the
Central Bank prints money, that money gets sent
to the government, the government has the money
so the way you should understand QE is
that it is Central Bank prints money and
lends into the government does that make sense?
what is useful about this from the perspective
of our understanding is because that money
has basically been magic'ed up out of nowhere
it makes it really clear how when
the government spends this money
which is run runs a deficit, how that increases
the amount of money in society right so sound
the government I borrow money from the Central
Bank 700 billion pounds what 450 billion pounds
at this point you're not affected right it's just
the transaction between the government and the
central bank but when the government then gives
that money out it's it's brand new fresh money in
society and that 450 billion is created so it's
it's in the case of the QE quantitative easing
funded deficit it's really clear how this just
leads to increased cash holding in society right
it's couldn't be clearer really the government
prints it it goes through the private sector but
it ends up being led to the government and then
the government just gives it out and I think this
captures something which we spoke about in last
week's video the "What is Money?" video which is that
the Central Bank cannot give money out they can
only lend money but government can give money out
so the Central Bank lent £450 billion to
government 450 of the 700 and the government
gave that out and this at the beginning of Covid
that number was 250. we could see then that it
was going to be increased but it was basically
that simple understanding which enabled me to
make a lot of money trading at the beginning
of Covid because you could see okay
the government... the central bank has only lend
250 billion to the government the government's
going to give 250 billion out we know someone
is going to end up with a ton of cash even
250 billion is still £5000 for every adult inthe
country right so we knew there's going to be
a ton of money given out right someone has to have
the money, people have more money, it's going to
push up prices, asset prices will go up and this
is how it was very predictable from the beginning
of covid that for example house prices would
increase now most mainstream economic pundits
were predicting a collapse in house prices but if you
understood well you know the government and the
Central Bank together are giving a ton of money
out we know that actually it's much more likely
asset prices will increase so what is nice about
this QE funded money even though QE itself can
be a bit confusing and I think you understand now
what it's meant by QE yeah? the Central Bank prints
money and lends it to the government what is nice
about it is it creates a very clean increasing
cash holding in society it's very clean it's very
clear because that money hasn't come from anywhere
it was printed by the Central Bank given to the
government and put out into society um so that's
450 billion of it and we know we know now it has
to be held by somewhere it's like if you pour 450
liters of water into a swimming pool you know
that that water has to be in there that money
has been poured into society and somebody has
to have it somebody has to have it nice and easy
um one little thing I will add on this is that the
Central Bank pays interest on that money so even
though the Government and the Central Bank between
them have created this money, it is still basically
interest bearing debt because the central bank
pays the base rate on that money and the base
rate has gone up and up so now the Central
Bank actually has the pages open that money
another thing is this creates an interesting
situation where the government owes a lot of
money to the central bank and the central
bank is is essentially a part of government
so it raises the question of is this really
government debt and I would say yes it should
be counted as Government debt because the Central
Bank pays interest on it so you're paying interest
on it like any other debt and technically it is
included as part of the government debt okay so
700 billion is the total deficit 450 billion of
that funded by QE we know that because that's
brand new fresh money that exists in society
somebody has to have it it's not complicated
you follow that? the other 250 billion is funded in
the more traditional sense of government borrowing
and what that means is it borrows money from
pension funds from wealthy individuals
a lot of the time you think you have money
in the bank your bank would actually use
that money to buy a government bond
and will be holding governmentbonds
so essentially the money in your bank
account is used to buy government bonds
and it's a little bit more complicated tounderstand
now... okay is society richer now because
in the case of the QE it was absolutely brand
new money poured into society okay now let's
consider what happens if the government borrows
250 billion and then spends it into society
okay so imagine your your Society okay and
you've got you've got 100 pounds I walk into
the room and I borrow that 100 pounds off
youand I give you an IOU, are you richer?
not really you used to have 100 pounds now you've
got an IOU for 101 pounds so if you include interest
but then I give the 100 pounds back to you
are you rich now? see what what makes
society richer is not the government
borrowing it's the fact that the government
borrowed the money and then gave it back
so if I borrow money from you and then give you
the money then you have the credit and the money
and I think what makes it even neater is often the
bank does that basically without you knowing so
you have 100 pounds in the bank the government
comes and borrows 100 pounds from the bank and
then gives you the hundred pounds which you
put in the bank so now you have 200 pounds in
the bank so the answer is yes you're richer if
somebody borrows money from you and then gives
that money to you, you are richer because you have
the money and the credit and often all you see is
an increase in your bank account because the
borrowing goes on by your bank your bank lends
the money to government, the government gives
themoney to you and you are richer so it's um
it's not that complicated really if somebody borrows
money from you i.e the government and then gives
you the money, you double your money, does that make
sense to you? it's you know.. and I could do it again
right you know; you've got £100 I borrow it
from you & then i give it to you now you've
got £100 and £100 borrowed.. like now.. £100
also owed to you okay you lend me another
£100 pounds & I give it to you again you know so
of course of course that makes society richer so
basically the end point here is no matter
how the government funds it's borrowing
be it by printing money or by borrowing money
from individuals if the government then gives
that money out society has more money it's as
simple as that you know if I if I borrow money
from you or if I print money and give money toyou
in both cases you end up with more money and
it's important to understand that this is not
this is not about lending money into the system
and most traditional economists when you talk
about people having more money they will think
about increased lending this is about giving
this is about the government going into debt
and giving money into the system which means
that the rest of society must go into credit
and must accumulate money and if anyone
doesn't understand that I would encourage
them to go watch last week's video what
is money that explains very very clearly
the monetary system is always in balance in
terms of who is in debt and who is in credit
so there, that's what it is basically the £700
billion is the total amount of moneygiven
out by the government above taxing, if the
government tax isn't spent that doesn't increase
private money holding it just moves around
but if the government prints and spends
or borrows and spends that does increase
money held in society and it then becomes
important especially if the amount of money is
enormous to understand who is getting that money
so I've said it many times before andI'll say it
again £700 billion is£14,000for every adult
in the country so ifthe government
has given that amount of money out
whether it's been printed or whether it's
been borrowed the distribution of wealth
and the distribution of money in society will
have changed enormously and it's important to
understand anyone who has not gotten £14,000
richer you have effectively gotten poorer because
other people have gotten richer um but yeah
that's it that is that is the number the number
we'll put a link in the description so people
can see that it's increasing government debt
um when the government gives it out somebody
gets it it's it's it's not complicated
um and if other people are getting it and not you
that will have social and economic consequences
which we'll go into in the next video um partly
it's funded by QE and that's nice and simple
because in that case it's brand new money partly
it's borrowed it's funded by borrowing but in that
case as well it increases money held in society
because if somebody borrows money and gives
it to you then you have more money um the next
couple of videos we're going to go through
I think the other couple of important things to
understand which is number one who actually did
get the money um we've covered it many times in
the channel but you know mainly in the first ever
video on the channel which is two and a half years
ago now so we probably we've got a lot of new
viewers you might have seen that so we'll cover
that quickly and then we'll go over basically what
are the economic consequences because I think the
way that that ripples through society is actually
really interesting but the main point of this
video what is the 700 billion pounds?
it is the total government deficit since the
beginningof covid, part of its printed, part of it's
borrowed but all of it increases cash holdings in
society it's enough to give 14 000 pounds to every
single adult if you don't have that, somebody has
that, we need to know who has it... okay that's it
money currently is flowing from the
government to the rich leaving the
government with big powers of debt and
the rich would be part of money there's
one other thing they can do with that massive
amount of income they can buy your mom's house